alright we're going to show you how to
create a cursor loader in three easy
steps we start by creating an integer
constant for a loader ID then we
implement the loader callbacks finally
we initialize the loader with the loader
manager we start just by creating a
loader ID which is an integer constant a
single activity can use multiple loaders
and they are differentiated by these IDs
then we have to fill in the loader
callbacks the loader callbacks are a
generic interface class with one
parameterised type when we use the
loader callbacks with a cursor loader
the parameterised type we use is cursor
which makes the callbacks look like they
do here the most interesting one for us
is on create loader on create loader
returns a loader with parameterised type
cursor this is where we create and
return our cursor loader cursor loader
has a constructor that takes all of the
standard content provider query
parameters and will call the content
provider on our behalf when it is
executed by the loader manager since
cursor loader derived from async task
loader it will be executed in a
background thread unload finished is
called when the loader completes and our
data is ready to use the data in our
cursor adapter we just call swap cursor
but this is where we would also perform
any other UI updates we'd want to make
when the data is ready on loader reset
is typically only called when our loader
is being destroyed it means that we need
to remove all references to the loader
data to do that we call swap cursor on
our cursor adapter with null finally we
use the loader manager to initialize our
loader we pass in that voter ID the
loader callback we just filled out and
an optional bundle this will do all that
cool lifecycle stuff we covered in the
loader intro such as calling on create
loader if the loader doesn't already
exist when using loaders in a fragment
we initialize our loader in the on
activity created method and that's it
you've got a basic cursor loader we're
going to have you write one for our next
exercise